Circe's mercury it's a liquid metal it's
one of them well one liquid metal at
this temperature there are a couple of
other liquid metals a little bit more
exotic places in or in the world like
Spain or perhaps Africa but mercury its
chemical formula Hg the best way to
remember that the formula for mercury is
like HG Wells HG mercury comes out of a
well mercury is one of the few elements
that is liquid at room temperature or is
the only metal that is liquid in room
temperature unless you live in a very
hot country it's also very dense and it
has been known again since very early
times mercury is very poisonous it's a
really fantastic liquid it was really
used for for making scientific
instruments like barometers and
thermometers you know and it's really
quite a beautiful matter I really loved
it when I was in school we used to put
it on the bench and play football with
it but you know lots of people don't
like us to do that anymore but what I'll
do is I'll just pour a little bit of the
liquid metal into this beaker so we can
see the properties and you can see that
it's really nice flows just like a
liquid but forms really quite nice balls
and you can see they're really quite
high meniscus forming around the mercury
it can get into the human body
particularly in the brain where it gives
signs of madness it used to be used in
the UK for making hats I'm not quite
sure what they did with Mercury to make
hats but this is where the expression
mad as a hatter came from because the
people making hats breathed in load
through vapor and this caused them to
show signs of madness so here we can
slosh it around a little bit but we've
got to be very careful that we don't
slosh it too much because it's extremely
dense and heavy it's very very easy to
go through the middle or the bottom of
the glass bottle itself tell me why you
weren't touching it with your hands well
mercury it's associated with toxicity
especially for the salts so you know we
like to try to minimize the contact with
them with a mercury and the mercury salt
as much as possible really just so that
we can be very careful with our health
and safety there was a tragic case in
Japan in
1950s when mercury got into the sea from
chemical emissions from factories and
the organisms on the bottom of the sea
turned them into the mercury metal into
a compound that could be absorbed by the
fish and particularly the shellfish and
then the fishermen and the people living
around this Minamata Bay started eating
these things and got large amounts of
mercury in their brain and that I can't
remember the number but several thousand
people got very ill and many of them
died so mercury in the environment is
quite a serious problem
it is also an interesting point that
mercury has been used for making
chlorine by putting electric current
through solutions of salt and it is
gradually being replaced
but unlike chemicals you can't get rid
of an element so if you have mercury you
can't burn it or destroy it in any way
and so there are problems now what to do
with the mercury that people no longer
want but it's a really beautiful element
really fantastic it's used often in
electrochemistry because you can form
very very good electrical contacts with
mercury and in fact many people that
might have old telephone or old bells
you know the doorbells that we have on
our on our front door inside the
bing-bong it's a mercury actuated switch
that turns on a magnet and off a magnet
very very quickly really beautiful
mercury has an interesting property that
it will very easily form alloys which
are called amalgam
my teeth and probably many of your teeth
are filled with so-called silver amalgam
which is a mixture of mercury and silver
which when it's freshly mixed is like a
paste but when the dentist pushes it
into your tooth then hardens and all
being well doesn't come out or at least
doesn't come out from number of years
but amalgams are not very strong and
many years ago when I visit worked at
another
université mercury was being stolen from
the university from the chemistry
department and nobody knew who was
stealing it until one day the window
cleaner was walking out of the building
and the bottom fell out of his bucket
because he had been stealing mercury by
pouring it into the bottom of his
pouring it's his bucket and hiding it
below the dirty water and the mercury
started to amalgamate with a metal of
the bucket it was a metal bucket and
eventually the bucket could no longer
hold the way to the mercury and it
suddenly fell out on the mercury all
came up